la situación que vive el ecuador es una
situación bastante compleja en razón de
la delincuencia de un auge delincuencial
el incremento en los grupos organizados
y sobre todo relacionados con el
narcotráfico violencia tanto en el país
en todo el país como al interior de los
centros de rehabilitación también han
puesto en vilo al al estado por lo que
el presidente de la república ha
decretado el estado de excepción en tres
provincias esto es importante determinar
este estado decepciones focalizado no es
a nivel nacional porque el presidente ha
justificado que estas son las provincias
en que la violencia es mucho más más
está mucho más reservada no está mucho
más más más grave es mucho más grave y
esto determina que solamente sea en
estas provincias la la declaratoria
estado acepción y las medidas que están
relacionadas y que otras implicaciones
además del toque de queda y el
despliegue de fuerza pública contempla
esta medida
bueno la declaratoria de estado
excepción tiene únicamente como medidas
la movilización de las fuerzas armadas
en conjunto con la policía nacional a
fin de detener el auge delincuencial y
también tiene como medida generar un
'toque de queda' de 11 de la noche a 5
de la mañana en determinadas parroquias
esto también es importante no en toda la
provincia sino en determinadas
parroquias de las provincias que están
en emergencias declaratoria de estado de
emergencia y qué tan eficiente puede ser
el estado de excepción en medio del
contexto que vive en esas estas
provincias
no no tiene una eficiencia una
eficiencia inmediata vale vale decir la
corte constitucional del ecuador ha sido
enfática en señalar al gobierno nacional
que los problemas de violencia de
inseguridad no se resuelven con estados
de excepción sino con políticas públicas
no porque estamos hablando de problemas
estructurales si bien pueden tener una
solución
y de alguna forma en los días en que la
declaratoria de esta acción está vigente
es decir en los 60 días que tiene
vigencia el el estado de excepción pero
no es algo que vaya a solucionar de
lleno a profundidad un problema
estructural grave que tenemos en el país
como es la violencia relacionada con el
narcotráfico
jimena usted muchas gracias personales y
por compartirlo con nosotros en france
encantado